person that oh my gosh guys what mbti
i'll get into astrology next if you want
but wouldn't it be ti type you know i i
don't know the code but i know the name
executive uh assertive or something
i don't know i don't know what am i
because you made me do that test i'm in
uh
hold on
i'm a i'm something with an eye i
remember
[Music]
yeah e-i-p-t i guess i don't know ptsd
pcsd
emtj that
who's he who's that who's that
dude you want to explain what this is
because i think a lot of our audience
might not know what oh i don't know [ __ ]
i just like asking this
it's like do you know yours
infp is that like the artsy one yeah i
think so because there's one like it was
a woman with like butterflies yeah and
i'm like oh
that might be my one as well that sounds
familiar yeah maybe i had an eye in my
mind mine was a woman who looked stern
i don't know what that says about me i'm
funny you're stunned i guess i'll
explain what this is because i'm like
i'm sure a lot of our audience are lost
right now it's just like they're just
saying letters they're just saying
letters right now fun personalities it's
not anything serious yeah yeah
i think all to do it though it's like
it's like 16 questions is it no no no
personalities yeah it's it's it's like
astrology but for psychology i think
right yeah that's so psychology
astrology for psychology i think it's a
fun like conversation starters
it's a very rough way of kind of saying
i'm kind of like this yeah this is what
i would say i focus
put my personality into it yeah i mean
it makes more sense than astrology
at least you know because yeah it has
like i guess logical steps to categorize
you but it doesn't always mean it's like
100 accuracy i mean there's more than 16
personalities out there i'm sure
that's it that's the cap it's really
nice and neat we love yeah we love it
that it's 16. it just doesn't make sense
really
i never do do you believe in like the
astrology stuff no no but it's funny
it's funny yeah it is i i think it's
more fun than some of my friends are
very into it i'm like oh you're a
scorpio yeah your scorpio with a scorpio
rising and your moon is taurus that
means like at this day they're like
super into it i feel like it's just an
excuse for like women to be racist
sometimes
it's like the highest form of classism
think about it whatever anyone actually
like talks about and i i i cannot be
near a scorpio you're like what's wrong
with you
i'm a leo oh yeah
see what i mean so you can judge me wow
energy coming from you right now yeah i
can't believe i i don't know how it's
just like everyone born in july is just
this this [ __ ] weirdo who's like
has [ __ ] rulers and it's like
a real word yeah right he does get a
very angry but do you know what you are
yeah i'm a gemini gemini yeah yeah oh
yeah it makes sense
[Laughter]
yeah because like for like the for like
about like 10 weeks straight we just
could not stop bringing up arcane after
it launched because it's so good right
yeah yeah yeah yeah exactly and also
we're like league players kind of
yeah
oh what wink are you guys when i used to
play i was diamonds no no no no no like
now
i haven't played in like two years yeah
i haven't played what are you bronze
so i would now no i am now
i feel really bad sometimes when people
watch arcane and they're like oh wow i
want to try leaving yeah yeah yeah and
they go into game and it's nothing like
yeah yeah it's it's like everything
about arcane wants me to like wants to
get me to play league again and like i
play one game and i reminded like why i
stopped playing league i mean the only
thing that's like accurate between the
game and the the show is that like
there's racism between like the
characters and stuff
that's like that's pretty accurate
it's a fantastic you don't even need to
know about nato too
you know we played league on the eu
server and the eu server is uh that's
just awful oh yeah
is there a single good server no but but
like europe because obviously you shove
all the european countries on the wall
and then everyone's like you know
everyone just bullies french people
immediately yeah what does this stand
for
it's gamer subs gamer subs game of sops
yes oh wow that's cool i like the big
anime girls giving them a free shout out